la nouvelle est tombée comme un couperet
le rhum subir à bien une augmentation de
3 euros 50
pourtant il ya deux jours annick
girardin ministre d outre mer était
convaincante elle promettait
publiquement la révision de cet
amendement qui selon elle risque
d'anéantir l'économie en outre-mer cette
mesure aura un impact sur le tissu
économique des dom et notamment dans la
production de rhum qui bénéficier d'une
exemption de vignettes cela représente
un ajustement de 1 à 3 euros par part
bouteilles et les acteurs de la filière
600 e mail préparer à compter de 2020
on va donc pouvoir proposer et le
gouvernement le fera un étalement de la
mise en place de ce dispositif qui
débuterait en 2020 et pourrait s'étaler
sur une dizaines d'années les membres du
cos des roms de martinique s'insurge il
avait jusqu'en décembre pour remettre au
gouvernement une étude sur la question
de la consommation de rome dans le pays
cet amendement est passé comme une
lettre à la poste à l'assemblée sans que
personne ne songe répercussions
économiques qui nous ne comprenons pas
pourquoi aujourd'hui alors que nous
avons une démarche en concertation avec
le gouvernement sur un sujet très
important qui l'alcoolisme
une démarche brutale et est opérée
menaçant clairement nos métiers
notre profession de la canne et du sucre
et du roman d'ici trois semaines le
texte sera soumis à l'avis du sénat le
coût des roms redoutent la fermeture des
petites distillerie les licenciements en
masse la production de roms représentent
15 mille emplois en martinique